[Music]
good morning
and welcome to trevor phillips on sunday
it's been the sort of week when things
in politics have been turned on their
head
first chesham and amisham turned from
blue to orange
as the lib dems pulled off a big
by-election shock
and this morning john berko announces
that he's trading conservative blue
for labour red the latter news is
admittedly less of a shock but the
surprise by-election defeat
is enough to leave boris johnson feeling
pretty blue himself
especially as he also tackles rising
cases of the delta variant
rebellion over his planning reforms and
a perilous situation
with the orange men in northern ireland
well with all those stories and more
we've got plenty to discuss with our
guests today
in just a moment the justice secretary
robert buckland will be joining us
we'll be joined by john burko for his
first tv interview
since announcing his defection to labor
i'll be asking sir ed davey if
this week's by-election victory is a
one-off or the start of a lib dem
surge shadow housing secretary steve
reed will be on the show
and we'll be talking to the former chair
of the social mobility commission
alan milburn about catch up in schools
and what it means for
levelling up but first let's
go to westminster where we're joined by
the justice secretary
robert buckland mr buckland um
let's start with kobe the airline pilot
union this morning is saying
that their industry is being devastated
and it's time
to lift some of the travel restrictions
perhaps a vaccine passport can you offer
them any hope
well i think the system we devised
trevor was designed to
give the highest degree of hope
consistent with the need to contain and
control
the virus i think that uh inevitably
in a situation as unprecedented and
demanding as this
there are going to have to be
significant trade-offs and it's clear
that
uh holidays as normal or travel as
normal was never going to be the case
bearing in mind the rise of particular
variants most notably the delta variant
i think all throughout this crisis we've
tried to strike the right balance
between the natural need in some cases
for
international travel but also the
imperative of making sure that we do
everything we can at home
to contain and prevent inadvertent
spread of new variants of concern
you know this is a hugely difficult
situation i think of omelettes and eggs
i'm afraid
but we are doing our very best to
maintain that balance with regular
reviews
of the regulations to allow the maximum
flexibility
but it is time to at least offer them
something there must be some
possibility of a move surely well of
course
regularly my colleagues in the
department for transport
are working on uh reviewing uh the
the mechanism and indeed the uh applying
the tests that we apply
to uh the the red amber green system
uh and changes are made sometimes
changes in
in a direction that will help travel
sometimes regrettably changes
in the other direction that's continuing
work we're not sitting
uh we're not standing still on these
matters um
and that will continue uh guided by the
evidence that we have
okay these are decisions for ministers
the telegraph this morning
claims that matt hancock will withheld
information
from the prime minister the chancellor
and from michael gove
about just how successful the
vaccination program had been
and that suggests that had the prime
minister
known about that data then perhaps
lockdown would have been lifted earlier
is there any truth in that sadly i'm
afraid that that report is wrong
uh the data that was provided the data
was provided
uh to the prime minister and other other
members of that cabinet committee
uh in the most up-to-date way before the
decision was made on monday
and the those taking part in the meeting
had
all the relevant data uh in the in the
most up-to-date way before the decision
was made there's no question of the
prime minister not being cited
on important data it was provided to him
and other members of that committee
in in the normal way as people would
expect okay well that's clear
can i just ask a personal question here
um
my daughter told me this this week that
she is going to get
married is there any possibility that if
she opted for an open-air
wedding that actually she'll be able to
have more than 30
guests well indeed the uh reforms that i
announced today relate to the uh
flexibility within
existing approved premises to have the
wedding ceremony
out of doors and that does create
greater flexibility for premises in
order to have
more guests in a safe way having a
wedding outdoors
it would be a civil wedding it can't be
a religious or a church of england
wedding
but a civil wedding or civil partnership
ceremony uh being able to take
place out of doors as opposed to inside
the premises
will indeed allow for that greater
flexibility obviously each premises will
have its own
guidance and its own rules but it just
allows couples
that to be to be more imaginative about
the way in which they can accommodate
friends and loved ones
to what is the most special day in their
lives great so
that means that our family of which
there are many hundreds we'll all be
able to turn up so thank you
let's go to politics now um you went
down to a huge defeat
in cheshire and amisham not you
personally but your party
some 12 000 voters moved from blue
to orange on thursday many because they
think
they say that the tories have forgotten
their traditional southern supporters
in their mad pursuit of the northern red
wall
now um is that okay with you is that a
price you're prepared to pay
well first of all i don't accept that uh
that choice you know the idea that
somehow
voters in the north or voters in the
south or an entirely different species
is is frankly patronizing and wrong i i
went out on the doors in cheshire and
amisham and listened very hard to the
concerns that were being raised
by residents about local issues hs2
development those sort of important
points being raised and clearly
the message has uh been conveyed very
strongly
in the form of that by-election uh
result
um but i think you know it's wrong to
say
that somehow the party has to make a
choice between people
and that you know somehow people in the
south are you know driven by
i think somebody said they were more
sophisticated i mean what what absolute
rubbish
uh you know people are people and ish
local issues on planning and development
exist all over the country clearly a
message was sent it's a strong message
it's one that we are
listening to very carefully and
considering carefully
um we want to succeed in all parts of
our country
and i can tell you certainly from my
point of view i've never taken voters
for granted
and i know that the mps i work with and
party campaigners
uh never take anything for granted as
this by-election
clearly shows to be clear nobody here at
sky thinks that voters in the south
are more sophisticated voters in the
north but you talked about the message
that you
heard from cheshire and amisham are you
going to listen
and change the proposals on planning
that would
make it easier for developers to build
and
harder for objectives to stop
development
but of course those proposals are being
developed and i think it's right
to clear up some some myths about this
you know the suggestion that somehow the
children's were going to be
bricked over and built over is a
nonsense because the chilton's is an
area of outstanding natural beauty in
fact
our candidate was proposing even
stronger protections and at no
time during this process have we said
that we wanted to start interfering with
greenbelt
or areas about outstanding natural
beauty for example
this is all about trying to deliver
housing for our children and our
grandchildren in an affordable way and i
think
every family in the country wants to see
their loved ones being able to get on
the housing ladder you know home
ownership
is an important part of who we are it's
a core tenant of what
certainly we believe as conservatives
and once it's been good to see an
encouraging rise in home ownership and a
a build last year which is the highest
in about 35 years
we've got more to do and choices to make
and i don't think we can shy away
from that yeah i hear what you're saying
about what you want to do
but as you say you've got choices to
make and one choice that you have to
make
is whether you will take away uh the
right to have a second line of objection
to development now in the white paper
you said you would
will you stick to that or not well
as i've said the white paper is the
first stage in policy development the
detail legislation is yet to follow what
i can say is that in those proposals
there are plenty of opportunities for
local communities
to have their say and to make their
voices
heard and the idea that somehow uh local
communities are going to be disregarded
or ignored is just
not the case it's a mischaracterization
of the proposals it's all about getting
that agreement before development even
begins you know for too often trevor
this has been a war
between objectors and developers we've
got to change the way we do planning in
this country
and i think it's right for our party to
be bold and come up with new ideas
so you're clear that that original
proposal is not
set in stone could change well look what
i'm saying is that the principles that
we've
we've set out which is our planning
system is now nearly 80 years old
and clearly in many respects is not
working well and not delivering
fairness to many many residents you know
i think all of us can speak with
experience of that
something must be done in order to
change that
get the balance right but also deliver
the homes that our country needs
development this morning just how sad
are you to see john burko
leaving your party well i think
to to to be to be fair to to john burke
i think he left the conservative party a
long
time ago i mean he's a private citizen
he's entitled
to make decisions uh about his politics
and i respect that
um what i would say is that i think as a
former speaker
he's somebody who even though he's left
office
does carry a degree of authority like
his predecessors
and i think that uh his predecessor's uh
authority was enhanced by their refusal
to go back into party politics it
certainly didn't stop them
speaking out i mean baroness boothroyd
is very forthright in the house of lords
for example and speaks out
on things that she believes passionately
in certainly doesn't stop them doing
that i wouldn't want to see that but
i think him joining a political party
actually
has the effect of diminishing the force
of his uh
voice in politics however strong he
wants it to be
let me understand that you you actually
didn't give john berko the opportunity
to go back into the house of lords and
make that sort of intervention
but are you saying that you think what
he has said today
conservative party xenophobic
nationalistic do you think he's
diminishing his office
well look i i first of all i disagree uh
totally with his characterization he's
got every right
to say that he's a private citizen and
he's made a choice
but he is a former speaker of the house
of commons and i do think that when
people get elected to that very high
office
they put party politics party politics
behind them
uh and i actually think that uh his
voice would have been stronger
had he stayed out of party politics
being free to express his views on
all sorts of things in the eloquent way
he always does but getting back into
party politics is something that no
previous speaker has done and i i would
uh
gently uh suggest that perhaps uh his
voice would have been strengthened
if he'd not made that choice uh that
he's announced overnight
let's go on to your own uh baileywick as
it as it were
um it's uh reported this morning that
you're considering intervening in the
colin pitchfork
case colin pitchfork who murdered two
teenagers
and uh is now thought to be
released under the parole board
jurisdiction
are you planning to intervene to stop
that happening
well the decision was made by the parole
board in early june i have 21 days to
consider
whether or not i ask them for a formal
reconsideration i'm working my way
through
that that very carefully i'm taking
advice on the matter and i'll make an
announcement
within that 21-day period as soon as
possible
this week you said that you were ashamed
of the government's record
on uh rape convictions 55 thousand
thereabouts reported recorded by the
police which only
about 2 000 were prosecuted just
under 1500 convictions um that is pretty
shameful
but besides ringing your hands about it
what are you actually going to do about
it
well the rape review contains an action
plan that is designed to
first of all get us back to the level of
prosecutions that we saw
about five years ago and the way we're
going to do that is by
making sure that prosecution and police
are working very closely together
in order to prepare the best possible
evidence to make sure that cases are
prepared as thoroughly as possible
and that there's a real focus uh on the
the alleged perpetrators very often
victims will say
it does seem to be all about me
everybody's focusing upon me and my
private life
whilst a disclosure and the importance
of fairness clearly is at the heart of a
criminal trial process
we do need to shift that focus and
that's what these proposals
uh commit to uh and indeed with further
support that i'm providing for
with regard to independent sexual
advisers uh sexual abuse advisors
we are working our way towards i hope a
return
uh at least to those levels and frankly
we need to go further
in order to increase confidence justice
secretary that that's
fair answer but it's what about it's
what everybody else is going to do
rather than what you
are going to do now your labour shadow
has
said that if you can't get the numbers
down into a respectable place the 2016
target you've just mentioned for example
in a year's time
you should resign are you going to take
up his challenge
well first of all i think that the
nature of that challenge and the low
politics of it
speaks volumes for the complete failure
by the labour party to actually come up
with anything constructive on this most
serious of issues i mean
it's also constitutionally illiterate
decisions made
to investigate and prosecute are made by
the independent
police and their operational uh work and
the cps which is independent
if there was any suggestion the
prosecutions were being brought about
because of political pressure on me
frankly it's safe it's a ridiculous
argument
um that's all about everybody else i'm
asking you about
you is number one is a target too
low um are you thinking it's the wrong
target
and what will you do will you promise to
resign if you don't manage to make
whichever target you set
but as i've said the idea that somehow
a resignation or political pressure
should be brought to bear on independent
prosecutorial decisions
it's not only bad politics it's actually
dangerous i'm not going to indulge in
that level of debate trevor i'm trying
to talk about
the serious issues i've rightly
acknowledged the position we're in i
don't
i've never sort of hedged from it i know
if no buts it's not the position i want
to be in
but the other agencies who are
responsible for this
have now got a clear lead we've all
agreed this document
we now need to get on with with
implementing it and that's what i'm
going to
help focus on together with the
independent agencies
okay i don't want to be flippant uh i
know that this is a serious program's on
but
um can i ask you this just how useless
is matt hancock
well i think he's useless at all in fact
i've known him for many years and i've
seen him step up
to the plate throughout this crisis
working tirelessly
on our behalf to make sure that the
response to covid the health service
response the health response
was as vigorous as possible it's been a
huge challenge for him a huge challenge
for all of us but uh to bandy around
words like that i think does
nobody er er er any service at all
uh he's been a most useful and dynamic
health secretary who enjoys our full
support
i just want to be absolutely clear about
this because i think you're treading on
dangerous ground here
because those are the prime minister's
words and
it appears to me you're disagreeing with
your boss well you know i'm not going to
get into
text messages or whatsapp messages sent
uh
between people and then disclosed in a
rather uh unfortunate way should we say
i i don't believe that that's
actually a reflection of the reality uh
i i've been working within
a cabinet within government throughout
this crisis and
uh i i don't detect any uh suggestion
that somehow
uh there is uh anything but the fullest
confidence in what matt has been doing
and what he continues to do so
energetically
robert buckland thank you very much
indeed thank you very much trevor
now british politics has involved its
fair share of weirdness in the last few
years
but eyebrows were still raised this week
when this happened
[Applause]
[Music]
yes that was sir ed davey the lib dem
leader knocking down a fake blue wall
after his party overturned
a big conservative majority to win the
cheshium and amisham by-election
mr davey says the lib dems are on the
march and gunning for other seats in the
so-called tory blue wall
but how realistic is that ambition let's
ask it davey
he joins us now
sir ed um standing result in cheshium
and damashum 25
swing in the famous words of one of your
predecessors
um are you preparing for government yet
look this is a huge moment for the
liberal democrats it's
a big moment in british politics and for
british people i think up until
we defeated the conservatives in
cheshire people thought
boris johnson couldn't be beaten that he
was somehow impregnable
now they know he can little democrats
show that boris johnson could be beaten
and i've
i've noticed how people are smiling more
today i think there's a glimmer of hope
uh that the conservatives can be beaten
the liberal democrats are going to do
that
uh in any safe uh conservative seat
particularly on the blue wall
seats uh we are gunning for them that's
right
i i love the idea that the whole country
is um
is smiling at this victory just in time
for the summer solstice but
seriously we didn't see anything as
as big as or dramatic as this swing in
the elections
last month so presumably you must accept
that there are local factors hs2 the
planning issue
that really contributed to this size of
swing
there are always some local factors but
actually on the doorsteps and i went to
cheshire mansion 16 times i talked to
hundreds of of people and the feeling i
got from them was they've been taken for
granted
by the conservatives many people on the
doorstep said i was the first politician
to knock on their doors and they'd lived
there for twenty thirty years
so people are not just in cheshire and
amish but across
the blue wall seats i think have been
taken for granted
and they saw liberal democrats listening
to them responding to them
and one of the things i heard was they
felt that boris johnson wasn't in tune
with traditional
conservative values and they were
worried about a whole range of
national issues as well so you know
i'm confident that we are seeing a
change in british politics
much bigger than people had been seeing
i think that both the pandemic
and the poles have have not have not
picked this up
um and there can be big shifts in
british politics we saw it in scotland
when the labour monopoly went we've seen
it in the north of england with
the conservatives on the march i think
the blue wall in the south can be
can be taken uh by the liberal democrats
uh in
in large numbers of constituencies let's
see if those uh
those high expectations um which frankly
we've heard before can actually be
fulfilled and you talk about
you know talking to people on the
doorstep um what will the liberal
democrats
leaflet at a general election say will
they say as your candidate
did in cheshire and amisham we are
totally opposed
to hs2 or will they say as you
have said in the house of commons we
support
hs2 as an essential aspect of
development of this country well if you
remember
cheryl gillan who sadly died and
triggered this by-election
she opposed hs2 on behalf of her
constituents in cheshire
she fought boldly against her own party
the conservative party who railroaded it
through
i think it's completely reasonable for
sarah green wanting to be the
representative for cheshire and
amsterdam to have an
independent voice but let's be clear
as well high speed links because it's
important to get more capacity on our
owes it's important to invest in public
transport
for climate change but that doesn't mean
we have to accept the way the government
are
implementing hs2 the way the hs2 company
is going about things because they're
not listening
to people in cheshire ambition they're
not that we felt on the doorsteps again
that they were being taken for granted
by the department for transport and by
the hs2
company david though i mean it's not
like you've got
hundreds of mps you've you know you
haven't got that many
to have different factions within where
will you
stand when you come to a national
contest
are you as a party going to be for hs2
or are you not going to be for hs2 well
listening trevor the hs2 legislation has
passed parliament
uh it's impossible to have another vote
in it a certain next few years
what is before parliament is a planning
bill
and both with hs2 and the planning bill
and many of the things
the conservatives have been taking
people for granted haven't been
listening
and the planning bill and the proposed
planning reforms which are
frankly a developer's charter were what
what the vast majority of people were
concerned about
in cheshire management because they're
worried that and on yet another
environmental issue the government is
saying one thing and doing another not
listening to local people
okay let's clear up um something that
seems to have emerged in the last couple
of days
liberal democrat path to government as
your predecessor nick clegg
showed probably lies through some kind
of alliance or arrangement or
understanding
with a larger party
you could reach an understanding with
labour not a formal pact
but you don't contest seats where one of
you can't
win are you up for that well i thought
it was interesting cheshire mamasham
lots of labandi green voters saw liberal
democrats not only just the best
party to beat the conservatives but also
liked our policies
and therefore you know i think it's uh
we shouldn't take voters for granted
should we
um i don't think political parties own
their voters and can't tell them which
way
uh to go you know i'm interested in
arguing for progressive uh policies that
are
in tune with uh people in britain and
i'm determined to make sure that we win
in those areas where we really are
competitive
and we showed how competitive we are in
cheshire and actually in the local
elections
before that just last month and we took
control of oxygen and cambridgeshire
uh councils for the first time we made
big gains in hertfordshire and surrey
and wiltshire
this i think gives credence to this
argument about the blue wall that the
liberal democrats can make advances
against the conservatives in that and i
think it would just be wrong trevor to
be honest
to say uh that people can't have a
chance to vote for a liberal democrat
canada or indeed a chance to vote for a
labor candidate yeah
but we know we but we know what this is
real politics
and i'm i'm detecting i'm detecting the
sense that
you're not going to be tremendously
upset if uh you as a party decide that
you're going to
concentrate your efforts in areas where
you can win
and where the labour party is more
likely
to beat the tories than you are that you
might
decide that you're not going to throw
all your eggs into that those particular
baskets uh
this is not formal but are we saying
that we are in that kind of territory
um trevor i think yeah the uh the
audience to this program will be
surprised to hear you say that it's
somehow unusual
for parties to go after areas where they
can win um you know you
we don't have a huge amount of results
no but you don't we need to fight
where you can't win i'm saying that the
liberal democrats under my leadership
will be a campaigning party we will go
out there and campaign for every vote
but we'll use our resources wisely first
past the post system it's dreadful
we want proportional representation we
want electoral reform but until we get
that we've got to play with the current
system
and that requires you to to concentrate
your
resources in areas where you're well
placed to beat the incumbent and that's
for the liberal democrats that's
almost entirely beating conservatives
so that sorry davey thank you very much
indeed thank you
well this morning john burko the former
house of commons speaker has defected to
the labour party
a conservative since his youth he served
as a conservative mp from 1997 until
2009
before occupying the speaker's chair for
a decade
government sources have told sky news
they're not surprised by the defection
after bitter rouse over brexit
made him many enemies in his former
party
well for his first tv interview about
the decision i'm joined here in studio
by john burko trevor good morning to you
good morning
um 25 years a long time
why leave now after all that time
well i was a member of the conservative
party for 29 years
but robert buckland spoke truer than he
knew
when he said that i left the
conservative party a long time ago
let's be crystal clear explicit
and accurate trevor i became speaker on
the 22nd
of june 2009 and that evening
in conformity with convention i wrote to
the then chairman of the conservative
party eric pickles
to tender my resignation as a member of
the conservative party
why because the speaker does not belong
to
is independent of separate from
unconnected with it
no support for opposition that's a
different decision any political part a
different decision you could have
rejoined when you stepped down
as speaker 18 months ago why didn't i
could have rejoined the conservative
party i didn't have the slightest desire
to do so and i
want to be fundamentally
clear and for there to be no dubaity
about this
as i said yesterday to
an observer journalist my values are
left of center
i do not identify with the conservative
party
and i think that in british politics
you've just heard from ed davey
most people still see it as principally
a choice between the conservative party
and the labour party
and the labour party is the alternative
government
to the conservative party if you believe
as i do
that this government is bad news unfit
to government and that the prime
minister though
a successful campaigner is a lousy
governor
you have to ask yourself do you want rid
of it and if you want rid of it
you have then to pose to yourself the
question and to answer it
how is that to be achieved and the
reality of the matter is in the united
kingdom
the only credible vehicle for the
removal
of this government is the election
of a labour government committed
inequality social justice
internationalism and a fairer and more
inclusive society i know that's the
labour brand i know you're a president
who chooses your words very carefully
john
you you've used this expression this
government's
uh i think three or four times uh this
morning
at what point did you decide you
couldn't be a conservative
was it when the conservative party was
taken over by
boris johnson or was it something that
changed in you
no it was something that changed in me
and i think oh so it's not boring i owe
it to myself
and to you and to everybody else to be
on the record about it and for there to
be no
uncertainty so if you're saying to me is
it principally about boris johnson the
honest answer that is
no and in fact there has been i think
already some confusion and
misrepresentation of that point
it's not personal against boris johnson
i do think that
he is someone who has only a nodding
acquaintance with the truth in elite
year
and i think that the utter contempt with
which he has treated parliament
is lamentable and i think it has
exacerbated
the very strong feelings of resentment
towards him
because i think a lot of people feel
that's not the way to behave
telling the truth in and to parliament
matters circumventing parliament is
wrong
treating parliament with disdain is
objectionable
but no i have over a long period evolved
my political thinking
i wasn't a member of a party throughout
my tenure tenure
as speaker because it would have been
quite wrong to be i didn't take a view i
sought to facilitate the house of
commons to express
its view and all individual members to
put their points across because that's
the responsibility
of the speaker now i'm a private citizen
as robert buckland says
i'm entitled to take a political view
and my view is a left-of-center view i
identify with
labor values labor principles labor
policies i'm going to come to labor in a
second but
um you've used the words xenophobic
nationalistic you have not just said
some
let's say less than fond things about
boris johnson it's the party you don't
like isn't it
and you don't like conservatives anymore
well i don't dislike
individual conservatives i have still a
number of conservative friends and i can
admire
and respect very much trevor people
across the political spectrum with a
vast miscellany of different views
on the understanding that they're honest
and principled and standing up
for the principles in which they believe
so it's not a question of personalities
it's a question of the issues but if you
say do i like the conservative party
the answer is no and i'm absolutely
clear
that i am not these days a conservative
so it's not
about boris johnson as tony benn used to
say it's not about personalities
it's about policies all right um you
know what they're saying aren't they
boris johnson didn't give you a period
and kierstarm will
now have that up well i can answer that
very simply i've had absolutely no
discussion
whatsoever either with kyostama or any
other member of the labour leadership
about that matter
there has been no barter no trade no
deal
whatsoever and if i may very politely
say so and i
do the people who make what they think
is that
potent and core skating criticism of me
are operating according to their own
rather low standards let's deal with the
issue
rather than impugn people's motives it's
got nothing to do with that
whatsoever before before we leave that
leader of the opposition conceivable you
might be watching this program
it might be occurring to him right now i
must bring up john and offer him a
period if he were to do that
what would you say well i think there's
a lot to be said
trevor for the old willy white law
adage personally i think it is best to
cross bridges only when one comes to
them
it isn't in my mind it's not part of the
game plan i haven't discussed it i'm not
waiting for it
what i'm motivated by is a commitment to
equality
social justice and internationalism i
believe
absolutely passionately and these are
the issues
that on leveling up the government
mouths the mantra
but it doesn't know the meaning of the
mantra if you
look at the recent record the
government's own education czar said 15
000 million pounds is needed to level up
and the government has offered less than
one tenth of that
let's focus on the issues slashing the
aid budget
it's wrong it's objectionable utterly
shameful we talk about these things a
lot on this program but
um you know we have the excitement of
having you here this morning so let's
talk about
you um it could be said
that this is a typical berko grand
gesture
to avoid speculation
as part of your legacy uh of the
criticism
of you uh as presiding over a culture of
bullying
in the house houses of parliament how do
you respond to that
that this is not really what you're
about what you're really trying to do is
to bury all of that i'm not trying to
bury
anything i think the suggestion that i
presided over that culture is quite
wrong
i'm not going to talk about individual
instances
because there is a confidentiality about
that process which
shouldn't be compromised or disrespected
in any way i can just say however there
was one individual who brought
a complaint of bullying against me it
was investigated and it was
rejected but i put to you again trevor
and i appreciate you've got your
journalistic responsibility
let's focus on the issues as far as i'm
concerned
issues that's what caused me to make
focus
um speak honestly to me i always do
do you can you say that you never did
anything
that you felt now you regret
or you thought might have been
objectionable or that might have been
something that
when you look back now you think i wish
i hadn't done that oh
in relation to this issue of bullying
and so on
gosh i would have to cast my mind back
we all make mistakes have i been perfect
in every instance
can i say that with the benefit of high
insight i'd never have done something
differently of course i couldn't
but i come back to the central
proposition one has as a private citizen
the right to make a judgment about which
political parties to support
i believe in terms of values the labour
party is preferable to the conservative
party and as far as kierstama is
concerned i don't know
whether he's going to make it
politically or not but i think he's an
honest decent intelligent person who has
come into politics
as the continuation of public service
and the real issue in my mind is who
has the vision of a more equitable
society who
thirsts to deliver social mobility who
wants to better the lot of people
less fortunate than a political leader
on on
that calculus armor is vastly preferable
to laura you've talked about labour's
values and policies
i have to confess i've been doing this
program for some weeks now i've yet to
drag anything that looked like a policy
out of a labor spokesperson
um what what is the policy or value that
you think labor has that really offers
this
i'll give you two examples one domestic
and one international
a domestic commitment to leveling up on
the proper funding
of education so that those who have been
dramatically damaged as a consequence of
the pandemic have the chance to recover
that's the first
example and the second example which
speaks to the dna of a progressive party
is that the labour party thinks it is
utterly wrong
and immoral to slash the aid budget
cutting provision for the poorest and
most destitute people on the face of the
planet who don't
live on a dollar a day they exist on a
dollar a day
okay that is wrong okay period i'm
afraid i have to ask
pretty much everybody who um has
experienced government
and been seen in conservative party this
today
matt hancock completely useless or what
well i think it would be fair for me to
say that
i would buy matt at my valuation
and sell him at his and realize a
healthy profit
in the process i think i've worked out
exactly what that means
well we'll see how hancock's fair thank
you very much
uh sean burke trevor thank you very much
indeed good morning to you
now we hear a lot of about leveling up
and john burke has just been talking
about that
it's been one of the prime minister's
key rallying calls in the last two years
but if the phrase is to mean anything it
will have to be about more than just
infrastructure it's also about skills
jobs
education and many teachers parents and
students
don't feel that the government's putting
its money where its mouth is
after just one and a half billion pounds
was earmarked recently for post pandemic
catch-up learning so some areas have
taken matters into their own hands
this week we went to south yorkshire to
investigate
pilliston grammar school in south
yorkshire is one of the oldest in the
country
founded in the 14th century today this
secondary school has a reputation
for excellence when i turned up this
morning to
attend this event intensely proud of its
history
the school holds a regular remembrance
service for the many former pupils
who lost their lives serving their
country
but in the past 16 months the head
teacher has been battling a host of
other problems
the first challenge obviously the the
covid uh covering 19 pandemic and the
restrictions around
students and and adults both teaching
and associate staff
coming onto on to school site first and
foremost it's been around students
mental health we've had a real focus on
on supporting students who have mental
health
their pastoral well-being also their
attendance to
online learning and also to attendance
coming back into school some of you
might watch today
and you might decide that you want to
improve your speeches for next week
that's absolutely fine like children
across the country
the pupils of peniston have struggled
throughout lockdown
just staying at home and not being able
to see anyone especially
teachers it was so much more difficult
to concentrate on because there's so
many more distractions
and at school you can get your head down
more and just concentrate on the work
but at home it's a lot more difficult
the government approach to catch up
funding has come under fire in recent
weeks for being
inadequate now local leaders here in
barnsley say
they're tired of waiting and are getting
their own checkbooks out
to help their pupils the school with the
backing of a local university
devised a mentoring scheme in which
children received
one-to-one coaching hello good thank you
how are you
good it's nice to see you next in person
this recent
graduate spent six weeks tutoring and
helping alison
in the run-up to her exams and today is
the first time
they've met face to face i had a
selection of students from um
schools within south yorkshire um it was
a six-week program where we covered
a variety of activities and workbooks so
roughly about 12 workbooks
um over the programme and we spoke
anything about anything to
do with skills future development future
planning
and careers exam and strategic sort of
learning
and calming strategies that kind of
thing it did help me a lot improve my
own confidence
in myself so to believe in myself
that i can do it that i can do my work
and just to try as hard as possible so
with that confidence in myself
and it gave me motivation as well to
carry on with my work
and get the grades that i i wanted to
achieve
the mentoring scheme was devised here by
members of the education department
at hallam university they worked with
local schools to allocate resources
where they were needed most with funding
from local government
what's been really crucial to the
success of this is we've co-designed it
with our schools you know we didn't say
this is what you need to do they said
actually you know we've got subject
specialists in our schools so actually
that's okay for us what we need is this
more nuanced
mentoring program boris johnson
repeatedly tells us
he's aiming to level up what he means is
targeting voters
in traditional red wall seats
he claims that one of the government's
priorities is education
dealing not just with the immediate
covet crisis
but also in the long term
but critics including those that run the
mentoring scheme in south yorkshire
say he's failing to deliver um i don't
think it's enough i mean i'll always say
there's never enough money goes into
education you know if we if we want to
thrive as
a nation then obviously you know we need
to invest in our in our young people and
the earlier we invest in our young
people
the better so i'll always say there's
never enough um
i also think there's been what what the
pandemic has done
as has exaggerated the gap in terms of
the north and the south in terms of
where money is is allocated
you know we know from the data that
schools in the north have been more
affected in terms of lockdowns and
isolations and disadvantage in terms of
equipment being available etc so
unfortunately what the pandemic has done
is is really highlighted that
so there's a real need for the money to
go where it's needed rather than um
you know a scattergun approach that will
that will suit everyone
the claim that there's not enough cash
is echoed here at the town hall
part of the funding to help the children
at local schools came from an already
squeezed council budget
and even funds the regional mayor had
set aside to run
his own office it is extraordinary that
i'm having to use money that has been
dedicated for something else
in order to make sure that our kids get
a decent uh educational opportunity
given everything that's gone on
but that is the nature of the funding
arrangements that we find ourselves in
and that's why i think it's really
important that the government
do go much further and provide much
greater levels of investment
so those kids who have been
disadvantaged as a result of lockdown
get every opportunity to catch up and
the mayor believes that all this
is symptomatic of a much wider problem
at the heart of the government
strategy if the government really want
to empower the north and not the huge
potential that exists here
they will work closely with me and
others and make sure that we've got the
tools to do the job
we want to work with the government we
really do but at the moment
we haven't yet seen the levels of
investment that we need to make a
meaningful difference
there's no doubt that the conservatives
are now appealing to millions of former
labour voters
who share a vision of traditional values
such as hard work
and patriotism but if the readies and
the resources don't follow the rhetoric
then the electoral gains of 2019 may
well be remembered
as little more than a missed opportunity
our piece from south yorkshire there in
response to that a department for
education spokesperson told us
as part of our ambitious and long-term
education recovery plan
we're investing over 1.5 billion pounds
for tutoring in schools and colleges
with over 500 million pounds going
directly to schools
and one billion pounds invested through
the national tutoring program
we're also giving over 900 million
pounds to schools which can be used
flexibly
to support pupils in the way that works
best for them
sticking to that theme of education data
released today by the social mobility
foundation finds that
disadvantaged young people have little
faith in the education system
a survey of over 1500 high achieving but
disadvantaged young people
the majority of them on free school
meals found that 38 percent are not
confident that they will receive
fair grades reflective of their ability
from the system
of teacher assessment in place this
summer
over half 52 percent are not confident
that they will be able to appeal grades
that they think do not
uh do not are not a fair reflection of
their ability
and on the theme of leveling up 58
percent of participants felt that not
all parts of the country
had suffered equally because of the
covid19 pandemic
well to discuss this further we're
joined by the chair of the social
mobility foundation
and former labour cabinet minister alan
milburn
we were um talking earlier uh about all
of this
uh alan um you've got some new data
this new data out today um what do you
think
this really tells us about the faith
that young people
have in the system well i think the
faith is pretty low self-evident from
from the survey that you just reported
trevor i think the real issue immediate
issue here is the
fact that the means by which assessment
for
gcse's this year is going to take place
isn't really taking account
of the disproportionate effect that the
pandemic has had
on the poorest kids you know they are
the ones who are least likely to have a
laptop
40 of them don't have reliable broadband
often they don't even
have a quiet place to study at home so
all of that should really have been
taken into account in the way that
schools go about assessing
pupils for the gcses and if you also
should be taken into account in the
appeals process
if a kid wants to appeal against the
results that they've been given
that isn't happening it should be
happening it needs to change because
otherwise what we'll have
is this ever widening gap between the
educational attainment of poor kids and
their better
peers and if that happens then you've
got yet another hammer blower against
social mobility in the country and i
don't think that's what the country
wants to
achieve i hope that it isn't what the
government wants to achieve so it really
needs to look at the assessment process
and the appeals process again
the thing that struck me most affordably
is that so many
thought that uh different parts of the
country had
suffered differently from covert when it
comes to
education what's behind that well i
think it represents
what you might call the new geography of
disadvantage in the country
um the there are parts of the country
that are doing really well and there are
parts of the country that are falling
behind so boris johnson is quite right
in my view to set this leveling up
agenda in motion
the problem is that leveling up at the
moment is a political slogan but what it
isn't is a real policy
now i hope that the prime minister's
appointment of neil o'brien the
conservative mp to put some flesh on the
bones of leveling up
will make a real difference but let's be
clear about it if you're going to tackle
these issues
it's going to require some fundamental
reforms it's going to be a long hard
journey it's not just about building a
few new
roads or relocating a few jobs from
whitehall you'll need reform in the
education system
in the labor market for example we know
that
the difference a really good teacher
makes to a poor child's education is
about an extra year of learning
what we ought to be doing in my view and
the government ought to take this
seriously is find new
ways to pay the best teachers to go and
work
in the most challenging schools because
if you do that then there is a chance of
leveling up actually happening you're
not going to get levelling up
unless you have a level playing field of
educational opportunity
government uh labor governments
including and unions have always
resisted the idea that there should be
if you like different rates of pay or
that there should be government
direction as there is
in france where teachers uh are located
are you saying that we need to
essentially
embark on reforms of that scale yes
i think there should be a reform of
national pay bargaining you know
it's no good paying that good teacher
the same amount to go and work in
the wealthy suburb school as to go and
work in a disadvantaged area because the
challenges are obviously far greater
going and working in a disadvantaged
school and this is the real crux of the
issue isn't it
there's a debate about is it that
somehow rather ability isn't evenly
distributed in our society or is it
opportunity well i believe
it's firmly the latter you can't have a
situation where
a disadvantaged kid from a poor area is
over 20 times more likely
to go to an inadequate school than
someone from a wealthy area
and believe that that's a level playing
field it simply isn't
so if you're going to make leveling up
work that has to be a redistribution
both resources of people in this class
teachers
and of opportunities it's not just about
mr johnson's obsession with capital
projects
important though they are roads and
railways and bridges and green projects
or free ports
it's about how you make sure that
opportunities in education in the labor
market are there for people
sort of people living in one of these
areas want to move up in society they
don't feel that they've got to move out
of their area
when it comes to moving up in society i
was very struck by some data that um the
social mobility foundation that you
chair
released a couple of weeks ago which
showed that 72
of the young people that you work with
think that
a young person's future depends on what
their parents
did or do and that increasingly
they decide well we're not going to
bother to try
in certain respect certain areas because
we know we're not going to
make it because our families aren't from
there does that
i mean that's pretty depressing isn't it
it's
it's pretty depressing but unfortunately
it's real we know that we have a social
mobility crisis in this country we've
had it
for very many years things are getting
worse not better you don't need me to
recite all the data but just hold on to
one fact
you know today only one in eight
children from a low income background
is likely to become a high income earner
as an adult
and it's unsurprising really that
parents and grandparents are worrying
that the prospects that we've all had in
our lives
to get on and move up in society are not
going to be available to the covered
generation
you know we had what a million young
people who are
unemployed half of the under-25s were
either furloughed had lost their jobs by
june last year
that is a real problem and frankly
right now neither the conservative party
nor the labour party
are taking this issue of social mobility
as seriously as they should be
and they really need to do that if
you're going to have a better society
and a stronger society then we've got to
make sure that generational equality
and not just racial equality or gender
equality or classic quality
are on the agenda and then need to be
far higher in my view
and um we've got a few seconds left and
i can't have you a former health
secretary who
really made big efforts at reform um
go without asking you what do you think
covid has revealed about
the capacity of government the machine
to cope with this kind
of of issue or indeed the general
task well look it's obviously been
an immensely challenging situation quite
unprecedented and obviously it's
involved
difficult judgments having to be made
continually some judgments have been got
right so
the nhs vaccine rollout program is
genuinely world leading
some failures are pretty obvious on ppe
for example test interests and also
the catastrophe really unleashed on the
care home sector which has been
a tragedy both for staff and for
residents so i think the real lesson
here
is one of preparedness we weren't
prepared for the pandemic
this will not be the last pandemic that
the world faces forever you know
we will need to be better prepared for
the next one that means that supply
chains
and equipment and pharmaceuticals and
drugs all need to be available
it also means that we need some
fundamental reform of the institutions
that have been undermined as a
consequence of covert
and most notably the social care sector
successive governments have talked about
that mr johnson is still talking about
it
it needs radical reform and not just
more money
of course there'll be more money that
will be needed but that is going to have
to come not just on the taxpayer it's
going to have to come from us as
individuals and frankly
we're going to have to save for our old
age and that would probably have to be
done through compulsory means
rather than voluntary that won't always
be popular but if we're going to avoid
the sort of situation that we've seen
now i have care homes this time around
if it ever happens again next time then
those are the sort of measures that are
going to have to be
grappled with we'll never talk about
this again and thank you very much
indeed
thank you craig well we've talked
earlier today about cheshire and amisham
it was never a race that labour expected
to win but they still had a pretty
shocking night losing their deposit
let's talk about that result and more
with shadow community secretary
steve reed
steve reed the constituency labour party
in uh cheshire and amisham has 629
followers on its facebook page
your candidate got 622 votes what what
happened to the other seven
well let's give her voters some credit
here
trevor because what what i think
happened is that voters took their own
decisions about the best way to defeat
the conservative candidate in that
by-election
so labour voters lent their support to a
liberal democrat who was best positioned
that's never been a seat where labour's
been competitive it's never been a seat
where labour's done
particularly well you know voters took
their own decisions and they defeated
boris johnson
and they defeated him for very good
reasons as well
but it's pretty grim isn't it i mean
this is a seat 55
remain 40 i think graduates it's a sort
of place that labor
should be doing well and needs to do
well if it's going to
compete for government again
isn't it worrying that if you look at if
you look at pete in this area
if you look across what happened in the
local elections in the south of england
just a few weeks ago
labour won the mayoralty of the west of
england we picked up seats in
hertfordshire we picked up seats in
sussex we're increasing our vote in kent
labour is doing well across the blue
wall in this particular
seat it was the liberal democrats who
were competitive now in a general
election
there will be only two alternatives for
prime minister boris johnson or
kia starmer so things may look
differently then as things were
on thursday the liberal democrats were
best placed to defeat the conservatives
and labor voters backed
the lib dem in order to get the tory out
and one of the reasons for that
was the hugely unpopular planning
reforms that the uh government is
bringing forward to deprive local people
of a
over of any say over developments on
their own streets
in their own neighborhoods so you know
there is a growing coalition across this
country
intent on stopping the conservatives
from continuing
uh on the path they're going along uh
about this country's future i i want to
come to the planning issue because
that's an area that i know you are
uh expert in but let's just talk about
the politics about this
of this for another minute or so did i
understand from what you've just said
that
however informal however unspoken
you think that the possibility
of essentially an anti-tory alliance
exists that would see the uh different
parties the liberal democrats the greens
the scottish national party essentially
combining
to get the tories out
well i didn't i didn't mean to imply
that at all uh trevor i
i'm not myself attracted you're talking
fundamentally about what's called
the progressive uh alliance so-called
and i'm not
attracted at all to the idea of
politicians trying to stitch up
the choices available to voters in their
own localities voters are smart
voters will take their own decision uh
and in cheshire
amisham they they took the decision they
took and in the west of england they
took a different decision
the key for labor uh is to win a
majority across the country
the blue wall is clearly crumbling now
but we saw in hartlepool the labour
party is having problems still
in some parts of former industrial areas
in different parts of the country
we need to build out now a policy and a
program that has broad reach across the
whole of the country
to secure the election of a labour
majority government
that is what we are focused on not
stitching up deals with other parties to
deprive voters of choice
so for you it's a labor majority or
nothing no alliances with the snp
no understandings with the liberal
democrats
well this is you know it's in the hands
of the voters rather than me how they
uh choose to vote how they choose to
vote but what kier is doing at the
moment and we've seen
the changes he's started to bring in
over the last few weeks is gearing the
labour party up to the next general
election he's appointed annalisa dodds
to head up a policy review our intention
is to build a policy
platform attractive enough uh to win
support
from across the country from majority
labor government that can bring our
party back together
after a decade in which the
conservatives have pulled our country
apart
and made us weaker both domestically and
on the world stage
well let's address policy um you said
that the planning issue was uh was a
major
uh question in cheshire and amisham
will labor support the government's
plans to
streamline the planning system and to
make it easier
to build homes and harder for people to
object to new developments
well as i'm sure you're aware we've
caught a vote in the
commons tomorrow uh on on some of what's
going on here and
what the conservatives are up to is
they've got a
a flagship piece of legislation that
they're bringing forward as part of
uh their new legislative program and
what it does it takes away
the rights of local people and local
communities
to object to developments that may be
happening in their localities power is
shifted
from elected councils on their planning
committees
to development boards that are appointed
by conservative ministers in whitehall
those development boards then zone your
locality
either for protection or for growth if
you're zoned for growth
then planning applications are deemed
accepted and even if you're going to see
a development on a green space like the
one i'm standing on now on or on the
street where you live
you as a resident lose the right to have
a say and to object
uh to that application this is a
significant reduction in people's rights
and the reason
the conservatives are doing this is
because under boris johnson's leadership
donations to the conservative party from
major developers have gone up by 400
so the conservatives are paying back
developers by selling out communities
and depriving communities of the right
to assay over developments on their own
street
now we're calling a vote tomorrow in the
house of commons yes to guarantee the
right of residents to object and we're
those conservative mps who have stood up
in the chamber so far
and said they don't like this well put
your money where your mouth is because
there's a vote tomorrow and you can vote
with us
to protect residents rights isn't the
outcome of all of that that essentially
labor is lining up with the nimbys who
say
we don't want new development in our
backyard even if that means
that young people who want to buy homes
there will be no homes
available for them isn't that
isn't that the outcome of what you just
said there's there's two points here
trevor i've got experience of this
myself i used to chair a
a regeneration board that developed that
brought forward 5 000
new homes the best development happens
when developers local councils and
communities work together
it doesn't work well when all the power
is in the hands of the developers and
everybody else is silenced from
having a say but if you want to look at
what the real problem is in this country
that is stopping homes being built
it's not the planning system that the
government is trying to change because
over the last
10 years a million homes have been given
consent
to be built but were never built the
problem isn't the planning system the
problem is developers not then going
ahead
and building them and the reason some
developers do that is land that has a
planning
uh consent on it becomes more valuable
and some developers will sit on that
land
wait for the land values to rise and
then seek to make a profit by selling it
on
without building their homes what we
need are better incentives to help
developers go ahead
and build the homes once they've got
consent not putting a gag around local
people's mouths
so they can't have a say about what
happens on the street where they live or
the community that they're part of
steve reed thank you for your clarity
this morning
pleasure that's it for the main show
today don't go anywhere though after the
break we'll be joined by our deputy
political editor
sam coats for trevor phillips the take
we'll be going over everything we
learned from our guests
discussing what it means and looking
forward to next week
that's straight after this short break
you